The relationships that we have with our siblings are often the longest-lasting relationships of our lives. Brothers and sisters are our first childhood playmates and our first rivals. In adulthood, siblings can be a source of friendship and emotional support. They're the only other people in the world who remember and understand exactly what it was like to grow up within our family. Yet despite their importance, sibling relationships are often overlooked and understudied, are seen as less important than other relationships such as romantic partnerships and parent-child bonds.
我们与兄弟姐妹之间的关系通常是我们一生中最持久的关系。兄弟姐妹是我们童年最早的玩伴，也是我们最早的竞争对手。在成年后，兄弟姐妹可以成为友谊和情感支持的源泉。他们是世界上仅有的、能够准确记得并理解我们在同一个家庭中长大是什么感觉的其他人。然而，尽管兄弟姐妹关系如此重要，它却经常被忽视和缺乏研究，被认为不如浪漫伴侣和亲子纽带等其他关系那么重要。
But psychologists and other researchers have insights to offer on how our siblings influence our lives from childhood through adulthood. So how can we get the most out of these relationships? How do our siblings affect us as children and as adults? What can parents do to help foster close relationships among their children? When parents play favorites, how does that affect the sibling bond? What can people do in adulthood to maintain and improve relationships with their own siblings? And what does the research say about the diverse types of sibling relationships that are more common than ever, such as half-siblings, step-siblings, and others?
但心理学家和其他研究人员为我们提供了深刻见解，让我们了解兄弟姐妹如何从童年到成年影响我们的人生。那么，我们如何才能最大程度地利用这些关系呢？兄弟姐妹在童年和成年期如何影响我们？父母可以做些什么来帮助增进孩子之间的亲密关系？当父母偏心时，会对兄弟姐妹的纽带产生什么影响？成年人可以做些什么来维持和改善与自己兄弟姐妹的关系？关于现在比以往任何时候都更常见的各种类型的兄弟姐妹关系（如同父异母/同母异父的兄弟姐妹、继兄弟姐妹等），研究是怎么说的？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. Dr. Lori Kramer, a professor of applied psychology at Northe, Eastern University and Emeritus Professor of Applied Family Studies at the University of Illinois, has studied sibling relationships for decades. She focuses on how young children can develop positive relationships with their siblings. Her findings have been widely cited in media outlets, including The New York Times, Time magazine, and the Today Show, just to give a few examples.
欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，主要探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天我们请到了两位嘉宾。劳里·克雷默博士（Dr. Lori Kramer）是东北大学（Northeastern University）应用心理学教授、伊利诺伊大学应用家庭研究荣休教授，她研究兄弟姐妹关系已有数十年之久。她的研究重点是幼儿如何与兄弟姐妹建立积极的关系。她的研究成果被《纽约时报》、《时代》杂志和《今日秀》等各大媒体广泛引用，这只是几个例子。
She's the creator of the More Fun with Sisters and Brothers program, which teaches children and parents, skills and strategies for building strong, positive sibling relationships. Our second guest is Dr. Megan Gilligan, an associate professor in human development and family studies at Iowa State University. Dr. Gilligan studies the links between family relationships and well-being with a particular interest in siblings. She's looked at how people's relationships with their siblings affect their health and well-being in middle and later life. She's also studied how people's perceptions of parental favoritism affect their relationships with their siblings. into adulthood. Dr. Kramer and Dr. Gillian, thank you for joining us. Thank you so much for having us.
她是“与姐妹兄弟共享更多乐趣”（More Fun with Sisters and Brothers）项目的创始人，该项目向儿童和父母传授建立稳固、积极的兄弟姐妹关系的技能和策略。我们的第二位嘉宾是梅根·吉利根博士（Dr. Megan Gilligan），她是爱荷华州立大学人类发展与家庭研究副教授。吉利根博士主要研究家庭关系与幸福感之间的联系，对兄弟姐妹关系表现出特别的兴趣。她研究了人们与兄弟姐妹的关系如何影响他们在中年和晚年的健康与幸福。她还研究了人们对父母偏心的感知如何影响他们成年后与兄弟姐妹的关系。克雷默博士和吉利根博士，非常感谢你们加入我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我们。
Yes, it's good to be here. So let's start with the broad question I raised in the introduction, which is how important are sibling relationships. Dr. Kramer, let me start with you because much of your research is on how to help children build positive relationships with their siblings. Why is this important? What do siblings add to our lives? And how do sibling relationships affect our development, health, and well-being? I think you've answered this question in so many ways, Kim, these are our lifelong partners. And I think it's really sometimes overlooked how important these relationships are. Your siblings, your brothers and sisters, they are with you throughout this life journey.
是的，很高兴来到这里。那么，让我们从我在开场白中提出的宏观问题开始，即兄弟姐妹关系有多重要。克雷默博士，我先问您，因为您的许多研究都集中在如何帮助儿童与兄弟姐妹建立积极的关系上。为什么这很重要？兄弟姐妹给我们的生活增添了什么？兄弟姐妹关系如何影响我们的成长、健康和幸福？我想你已经从很多方面回答了这个问题，金，他们是我们一生的伙伴。而且我认为，这些关系有多重要有时确实被忽视了。你的兄弟姐妹，伴随着你走过整个人生旅程。
They are people who really understand you, both your flaws as well as your strengths and assets. And they use that in many ways. But they're truly the individuals that we learn with. We develop so much of our character, of learning how to negotiate various social situations, other life challenges, and they teach us so much in so many ways. Dr. Gillian, let me ask you this. How much do the relationships that we have with our siblings carry through from childhood to adulthood?
他们是真正理解你的人，无论是你的缺点还是优点和长处。他们在很多方面都在利用这一点。但他们确实是我们共同学习的对象。我们性格的形成、如何应对各种社交场合以及其他生活挑战的经验，很大程度上都来自于他们，他们在方方面面教导了我们很多。吉利根博士，我想问您这个问题：我们与兄弟姐妹的关系从童年到成年延续了多少？
And do siblings who are close as children tend to remain close as adults? Yeah, so this is something that we're really starting to understand more, but it's a growing area of research. And so we do know that most individuals continue to maintain sibling relationships throughout their life course. So they maintain contact, exchange support. They engage in conflict as well as express feelings of closeness. So multidimensional relationships across the life course.
从小亲密的兄弟姐妹在成年后往往也会保持亲密吗？是的，所以这是我们真正开始深入了解的一个领域，但它是一个不断增长的研究领域。因此我们确实知道，大多数人在整个人生历程中都会继续维持兄弟姐妹关系。因此，他们保持联系、互换支持。他们既有冲突，也会表达亲密感。这是一种贯穿人生的多维度关系。
But one of the things we're starting to understand is that there may be some points in our life that siblings are more salient than others. So it does appear maybe adolescence as a time when we, maybe we're living at home together, we're sharing more experiences. Maybe as we grow and leave parental homes, maybe they kind of fall back a little bit compared to other relationships. But there is emerging research showing that we come back together with our siblings, certainly in later middle life as we age.
但我们开始理解的事情之一是，在我们人生的某些阶段，兄弟姐妹可能比其他时候更为重要。因此，青少年时期似乎是一个我们可能一起住在家里、分享更多经历的时期。也许随着我们长大并离开父母的家，与其他关系相比，兄弟姐妹关系可能会稍微退居其次。但也有新兴研究表明，随着我们年龄的增长，尤其是在中老年时期，我们一定会与兄弟姐妹重新聚在一起。
And so this idea of them being a lifelong relationship, it may vary across the life, course, but becoming even more salient as we enter into our later lives. So do siblings who fight a lot as kids and teens tend to have more difficult relationships as adults, or do they grow out of that and do the relationships get better as they get older? Yeah. So I would say in our family relationships in general, we do tend to see quite a bit of continuity. So there are some changes in our dynamics, but those patterns that we establish earlier in life, it's not often that we see them drastically change. As we develop and Dr. Kramer talks about interventions,
因此，他们作为终身伴侣这一概念可能会在人生的各个阶段有所不同，但当我们进入晚年时，这种关系变得更加重要。那么，小时候和青少年时期经常吵架的兄弟姐妹长大后往往会有更困难的关系，还是他们会摆脱这种状态，随着年龄的增长关系会变好呢？是的。所以我想说，总的来说，在我们的家庭关系中，我们确实倾向于看到相当多的延续性。因此我们的动态会有一些变化，但我们在早期生活中建立的模式，我们并不经常看到它们发生剧烈变化。随着我们的成长，克雷默博士谈到了干预措施，
maybe we can make modifications in our relationships, but research in general shows there is quite a bit of stability or continuity. Of course, though, we also encounter different life events and circumstances that can change those relationships. So our transitions as we might into romantic relationships, we might have children of our own, we might as we get older also have different relationships with our parents and inter-caregiving. So those life transitions and events may cause changes. But for the most part, the patterns that we establish early,
也许我们可以对我们的关系进行调整，但总的研究表明，稳定或连续性是相当显著的。当然，我们也会遇到不同的生活事件和情况，这些事件和情况会改变这些关系。因此，我们的生活转变可能会让我们进入恋爱关系，我们可能会有自己的孩子，随着年龄的增长，我们可能还会与父母建立不同的关系并参与照料。因此，这些生活转变和事件可能会导致变化。但就大部分而言，我们早期建立的模式，
we do see that we often carry them with us kind of throughout our life course. So if you were distant from your brother as kids, even when you grow up, you probably are not going to get super close. That's what you're saying. Yes, unless there was something, an outside intervention or something within your family that kind of changed that relationship, most of the time if you have a distance, absent, conflictual relationship, you're going to see stability in that. Same with if you have a really close solid foundation.
我们确实发现我们常常将它们带在身边，贯穿我们整个人生历程。所以，如果你小时候和哥哥很疏远，即使你长大了，你大概也不会变得超级亲密。这就是你的意思吗？是的，除非有什么外力干预或者你家庭内部有什么东西改变了这种关系，否则大多数时候，如果你有一种疏离、缺席、充满冲突的关系，你就会看到这种关系的稳定性。如果你有一个非常亲密坚实的基础，情况也是如此。
That's going to probably carry with you throughout the life course as well. We've seen that as well early in development too. So I've studied the beginnings of sibling relationships, looking at what it was like as this new child entered the family and followed these families until the older child was leaving the household for college or work. And so a great deal of continuity in the degree to which they interacted positively at every time point that we went to observe what was going on. I agree with Dr. Gilligan that unless there's someone, life force, some therapy, counseling, some intervention, we're most likely to see continuity in that quality, meaning that kids who are getting along pretty well tend to continue to do so, but those who are not tend to continue to have difficulties.
这可能也会伴随你一生。我们在早期发育中也看到了这一点。所以我研究了兄弟姐妹关系的初始阶段，观察了这个新孩子进入家庭时的情景，并一直追踪这些家庭，直到大孩子离开家去上大学或工作。因此，在我们去观察正在发生的事情的每个时间点，他们在积极互动方面的程度表现出极大的连续性。我同意吉利根博士的观点，除非有什么生活力量、某种治疗、心理咨询或某种干预，否则我们最有可能看到这种品质的连续性，这意味着相处得不错的孩子往往会继续相处得很好，而那些相处不好的孩子往往会继续遇到困难。
So following up a little bit, Dr. Kramer, in one interview with you that I listened to, you quoted kind of a striking number that young children on average have seven and a half disputes with their siblings per hour. It seems like fighting between young siblings is normal and frequent. But that's outrageous. I mean, I know I fought with my brothers like crazy, but seven and a half disputes per hour. And that's an average.
那么顺着这个话题再问一下，克雷默博士，在我听过的对您的一次采访中，您引用了一个惊人的数字，即幼儿平均每小时与兄弟姐妹发生七点五次争执。幼儿之间的争吵似乎很正常也很频繁。但这太离谱了。我的意思是，我知道我和我兄弟吵得天翻地覆，但每小时七点五次争执。而且这还是个平均值。
How did you measure that? Well, you know, we go into family's homes. We bring tape recorders or video recorders. We have all the adults leave and just listen to what kids actually do with one another. It's always astounding to hear. what kids talk about and what they do and what they play. But I was very interested, not so much in just arguments and conflicts that kids had, but those that were extended. So, you know, a lot of times a child might say something negative to a brother or sister and it just gets dropped.
你是怎么测量出来的？嗯，你知道的，我们走进家庭。我们带上录音机或录像机。我们让所有成年人都离开，只听孩子们实际上在互相做什么。听到孩子们在谈论什么、做什么、玩什么，总是让人感到震惊。但我非常感兴趣的，不仅仅是孩子们之间的争论和冲突，而是那些延长的冲突。所以，你知道的，很多时候一个孩子可能会对兄弟或姐妹说一些消极的话，然后事情就过去了。
Nothing happens. I didn't even count those. I was just looking at the ones where it was what I called extended. The other child reciprocated also with something negative, a negative affect or negative behavior. And we observed quite a lot in this age group. I do believe that number declines as children get older. I think that study was about three and a half year olds to six or seven year olds, if I'm remembering correctly. So it was pretty early in childhood. So this is happening quite a lot. But what was also astounding was that children don't seem to have the skills at that age to be able to manage conflicts on their own. And that is something that children can learn, that we can teach them, and that really makes a difference. And parents play a tremendous role
什么都没发生。我甚至都没有把那些计算在内。我只是在寻找我称之为“延长”的冲突。另一个孩子也用消极的东西、消极的情绪或消极的行为做出了回应。我们在这一年龄段观察到了相当多的此类情况。我确实相信这个数字会随着孩子年龄的增长而下降。如果我没记错的话，那项研究的对象大约是三岁半到六七岁的孩子。所以这是在童年很早的时候。所以这种情况发生得相当频繁。但同样令人震惊的是，孩子们在这个年龄似乎没有能力自己处理冲突。这是孩子们可以学习的东西，我们可以教给他们，这确实会产生影响。而父母扮演着巨大的角色，
in helping children to acquire those skills and use them. So what should parents do when kids are fighting the way that you observe? Should they let them sort of fight it out among themselves, or should they intervene? How do you know when it's right to do one or the other? I did this fun study where we wired up children with wireless microphones and let them go anywhere in their homes. I have some adorable photos of kids doing this. And we asked one day, a mother, to be in the kitchen listening to what was going on and another day of father doing this.
帮助孩子获得这些技能并加以运用。那么，当孩子们按照你观察到的方式吵架时，父母该怎么做？他们是应该让孩子们自己解决，还是应该介入？你怎么知道什么时候做哪一个才是正确的？我做过一项有趣的研究，我们给孩子们戴上无线麦克风，让他们去家里的任何地方。我有一些孩子们这样做的可爱照片。有一天，我们让一位母亲在厨房里听发生了什么，另一天让一位父亲这样做。
We also had a day, a practice day, just so everybody could get used to this process. And it was so interesting because we knew that the parents. could hear that the kids were fighting. There was no excuse. And they were listening to what the kids were doing and making a decision right then and there about whether to go intervene or not. This, I would say, was fascinating because before the study began, we asked them to complete a questionnaire about what they thought were the best strategies for intervening or not intervening when kids fight. And what they told us across the board was that letting kids work it out on their own was not an effective strategy. What they thought was most effective was joining the children
我们还安排了一天练习日，好让每个人都能习惯这个过程。这非常有趣，因为我们知道父母能听到孩子们在吵架。没有任何借口。他们当时就在听孩子们在做什么，并当场决定是否要介入。我想说，这非常迷人，因为在研究开始之前，我们让他们填写了一份问卷，关于他们认为在孩子吵架时介入或不介入的最佳策略是什么。他们普遍告诉我们的是，让孩子们自己解决并不是一个有效的策略。他们认为最有效的方法是加入孩子们当中，
and having a discussion about what was going on and asking each child to basically say what was happening for them and help them work it out. However, what they actually did under these circumstances was totally the opposite of what they told us was most effective. We also asked them, you know, is it hard? Is it easy to do each of these strategies? And what we learned was that while they believe that it's most effective to intervene to help moderate and mediate these conflicts with children, they don't know how to do it.
并讨论正在发生的事情，要求每个孩子基本上说出对他们来说发生了什么，并帮助他们解决。然而，在这些情况下，他们实际做的事情与他们告诉我们的最有效的方法完全相反。我们还问他们，你知道吗，执行这些策略是难还是容易？我们了解到的是，虽然他们认为介入以帮助缓和和调解与孩子的这些冲突是最有效的，但他们并不知道该怎么做。
So here you go. And that's, again, something that we can help parents do. But to answer your question, Kim, I would say that if you have young children, and in general I'm talking about children under the age of eight, it's very likely that they don't yet possess the skills to manage these conflicts on their own. And what we see is that when parents don't intervene, the conflict just continues. And it often escalates and becomes awful for kids and potentially dangerous for kids. kids. When parents intervene, there's a much greater likelihood that children are going to be able to successfully manage the conflict with parental coaching at that moment. Once parents are confident that their children do have the skills to manage these conflicts on their own, that's an opportunity
所以你看。这再次是我们可以帮助父母做的事情。但为了回答你的问题，金，我想说的是，如果你有幼儿，一般来说我指的是八岁以下的儿童，他们很有可能还不具备自己管理这些冲突的技能。我们看到的是，当父母不介入时，冲突就会持续下去。它往往会升级，对孩子们来说变得很糟糕，甚至可能对孩子们产生危险。当父母介入时，孩子们更有可能在父母当时的指导下成功管理冲突。一旦父母确信他们的孩子确实有能力自己管理这些冲突，这就是一个机会，
for parents to go and remind their kids that they need to work it out. So I would say it's a little of it subtle, but we do need to take into account the developmental levels of children when we give advice to parents. That makes complete sense. But what about the idea of like pulling the kids apart and saying, all right, that's it. You go here and you go there and you can't see each other for the next hour. Is that an effective strategy? We looked at separating kids. We looked at threatening kids with punishment. When parents follow through with that punishment or just one at the threat. We looked at other ways that parents sometimes use power their control to try to manage the kids' behaviors. And we saw that for the most part kids continue to find a way to
让父母去提醒他们的孩子，他们需要自己解决问题。所以我想说这有点微妙，但在给父母提供建议时，我们确实需要考虑儿童的发展水平。这完全说得通。但是，把孩子们拉开，然后说：“好了，就这样。你到这里去，你到那里去，接下来一个小时你们不能见面。”这种想法怎么样？这是一个有效的策略吗？我们研究了隔离孩子。我们研究了用惩罚威胁孩子。当父母付诸惩罚或仅仅发出威胁时。我们研究了父母有时用来控制孩子行为的其他权力方式。我们发现，大多数情况下，孩子们仍然会找到方法去参与冲突。
engage in conflict. It does not lead to constructive forms of conflict management. And again, I think an important point, too, is that it's not that we want to eliminate all forms of conflict between children. Conflict to actually serve some very important developmental functions. for children. They learn a lot by fighting, and they learn a lot by fighting with their siblings. And it's a very safe relationship for them to figure out how to do this, right? How to stand their ground in argue things. But really what we're looking for is helping children to develop the skills and competencies they need in order to successfully manage those conflicts so that they can have reasonable disagreements with a sibling, stand their ground,
这并不会导致建设性的冲突管理形式。同样，我认为一个重要的观点是，我们并不是想要消除儿童之间的所有形式的冲突。冲突实际上可以为儿童服务一些非常重要的发展功能。孩子们通过争吵学到很多东西，通过与兄弟姐妹争吵学到很多东西。对他们来说，弄清楚如何做到这一点是一个非常安全的关系，对吧？如何在争论事情时坚持自己的立场。但实际上我们在寻找的是帮助孩子发展成功管理这些冲突所需的技能和能力，以便他们能够与兄弟姐妹进行合理的争论，坚持自己的立场，
talk about their point of view, not necessarily give in to a more powerful sibling. But to do that in the midst of also having very positive interactions with their sibling. How do family dynamics like gender and family size influence sibling relationships? So, for example, whether you've got brothers or sisters or a large family with a lot of kids or maybe there's only one sibling, How do these family constellations lead to closer or more distant sibling relationships? I think across the life course, we noticed that sister-sister pairs do tend to be closer. So we notice that at different stages of development. But one of the things that we notice in the adult literature, and I think this may be true for the earlier literature as well,
谈论他们的观点，而不一定要向更有力量的兄弟姐妹妥协。但要在与兄弟姐妹进行非常积极的互动的过程中做到这一点。性别和家庭规模等家庭动力如何影响兄弟姐妹关系？例如，无论你是有兄弟还是有姐妹，还是一个有很多孩子大家庭，或者也许只有一个兄弟姐妹，这些家庭组合是如何导致更亲密或更疏远的兄弟姐妹关系的？我认为在整个人生历程中，我们注意到姐妹组合往往更亲密。所以我们在不同的发展阶段都注意到了这一点。但我们在成人文献中注意到的一件事，我想这对于早期的文献来说可能也是真的，
women are also more likely to engage in conflict with each other. So they may have these close relationships, but they also may have more intense conflict. So they're kind of involved in these more intense relationships with one another. So we noticed this with mother-daughter relationships, but also in our work on sister relationships as well. So I would think that is one factor. And then you also mentioned the sibling size. And we kind of know the more, the more people you bring into a group, you're kind of bringing in different perspectives and different personalities. And there can be more opportunity for conflict and engagement in conflict, the more people you bring in. So we do notice some of that in our work as well. The larger subships, trying to navigate those
女性也更有可能彼此发生冲突。所以她们可能有这些亲密的关系，但她们也可能有更激烈的冲突。因此，她们有点卷入了彼此之间更激烈的关系中。所以我们在母女关系中注意到了这一点，在我们对姐妹关系的研究中也注意到了这一点。所以我认为这是一个因素。然后你还提到了兄弟姐妹的数量。我们都知道，你带入一个群体的成员越多，你就会带入不同的视角和不同的个性。你带入的人越多，发生冲突和参与冲突的机会就越多。所以我们在工作中也注意到了一些这种情况。较大的同胞群体，试图驾驭这些
relationships and negotiate those relationships with more people can result in higher levels of conflict. What about when there's an odd number of kids in the family and they start building factions against each other? I mean, how do you deal with that? Yes, we sometimes refer to this as coalition building. We notice this in other aspects of our lives. And siblings can do the same thing. So if we can get someone on our side in these arguments or tension that we've been talking about, then we can have a coalition. And so that can be a sense of power in sibling relationships. And something definitely that we see as researchers and also something to think about when intervening or navigating in sibling relationships. It's also a strength, though, to be able to form a coalition with a sibling.
关系并与更多人协商这些关系，可能会导致更高水平的冲突。如果家里有奇数个孩子，他们开始互相结帮拉派，该怎么办？我的意思是，你如何处理这个问题？是的，我们有时把这称为联盟建立。我们在生活的其他方面也注意到了这一点。兄弟姐妹也可以做同样的事情。因此，如果我们能在我们一直在讨论的这些争论或紧张局势中拉拢某人站在我们这一边，那么我们就可以建立一个联盟。这可以成为兄弟姐妹关系中的一种权力感。这绝对是我们作为研究人员所看到的东西，也是在干涉或驾驭兄弟姐妹关系时需要考虑的事情。不过，能够与兄弟姐妹结盟也是一种力量。
To get somebody on your side, it's the developmental achievement in a lot of different ways for kids to be able to manipulate the situation, if you will, in some way. So it's not always a bad thing, but yeah. Yes, I completely agree. Yes, it's a dynamic to be aware of, but can be a useful tool for siblings to navigate. How much do we know about relationships with step siblings or half siblings or other kinds of people being brought into a household and acting as it? if their brothers and sisters mean being raised as children together?
让某人站在你这一边，对孩子们来说，在许多不同的方面都是一种发展成就，可以说是在某种程度上操纵局势。所以这并不总是一件坏事，但是，是的。是的，我完全同意。是的，这是一个需要意识到的动态，但可以成为兄弟姐妹驾驭关系的有用工具。我们对继兄弟姐妹、同父异母或同母异父的兄弟姐妹，或者被带入家庭并像兄弟姐妹一样行事的其他人（我的意思是作为孩子一起长大）之间的关系了解多少？
What do we know about the dynamics of those relationships? There's so much more we need to learn. These are very complex relationships. Not all siblings live together. And I think that, you know, number one, makes a huge difference. So when there's a remarried family, for example, some siblings may never live together. And it's really interesting even just to ask them whether they consider themselves to be, you know, full siblings, half siblings or not even. We now know that there are a lot of individuals out there who are biologically related as siblings that they didn't even know existed.
我们对这些关系的动态了解多少？我们还有很多东西需要了解。这些是非常复杂的关系。并不是所有的兄弟姐妹都住在一起。我认为，首先，这带来了巨大的差异。例如，当这是一个重组家庭时，一些兄弟姐妹可能从未一起生活过。甚至只是问他们是否认为自己是全同胞、半同胞甚至不是同胞，都非常有趣。我们现在知道，有许多人在生物学上是兄弟姐妹，但他们甚至不知道彼此的存在。
And that is absolutely fascinating. Adoptive families, foster families. there's so many different variations. We have so much more to learn. I would say a great deal depends on how, especially in early childhood, how parents talk about these relationships and introduce family members to one another or treat them kind of weighs into some of those issues about parental favoritism and differential treatment in very, very important ways. And I would say in the adulthood literature, this is something we have not thought or been looking at as much, but as the phenomenon of what we sometimes refer to as the gray divorce increases. So people getting divorced later in life and remarried and repartnered later in life, you may acquire step siblings in adulthood. And so what does that look like and what does that look like in terms of navigating later life caregiving or
这绝对是迷人的。收养家庭、寄养家庭，有这么多的变异。我们还有很多东西需要了解。我想说，很大程度上取决于（尤其是在幼儿时期）父母如何谈论这些关系，如何向彼此介绍家庭成员或如何对待他们，这在非常非常重要的方式上权衡了父母偏心和差异对待的一些问题。我想说，在成年文献中，这是我们没有考虑或没有那么多关注的事情，但随着我们有时所说的“灰色离婚”现象的增加（即人们在晚年离婚，并在晚年再婚和重新结成伴侣），你可能会在成年后获得继兄弟姐妹。那么这看起来是什么样的，在驾驭晚年护理或
dividing assets. So it's something that we definitely need to pay more attention to and more and more people are experiencing in their lives. So it's popular these days to talk about birth order as having an influence on a person's trajectory in life. There are some people who believe that the firstborn child will be a leader, but also neurotic. Middle children and I confess I am one will be the peacemaker and that the baby in the family is going to be more self-centered. I mean, these are just some of the stereotypes that are out there. Is there any good research to back up or to refute these thoughts? I tend to stray away from this idea of birth order is sort of a horoscope, of thinking about just because you are this birth order, you're going to be, behave in a particular
分割资产方面又是什么样的？所以这是我们绝对需要给予更多关注的事情，越来越多的人正在他们的生活中经历这种事情。所以现在人们普遍认为出生顺序会对一个人的人生轨迹产生影响。有些人认为第一个出生的孩子会成为领导者，但也很神经质。中间的孩子（我承认我就是其中之一）会成为和平缔造者，而家里最小的孩子会更加以自我为中心。我的意思是，这些只是现有的刻板印象中的一部分。有什么好的研究来支持或反驳这些想法吗？我倾向于抛开出生顺序就像星座这样的想法，不去想仅仅因为你是这个出生顺序，你就会表现得特别，
way or have particular characteristics or personalities. Instead, I like to think about the family environment in which children are brought into. So if you are a firstborn child, you're coming into a family where maybe there's two parents, maybe there's other adults in the household, but there's probably no other children. It's you. And your experience of being raised by these adults who are highly motivated to make sure that you're safe and healthy and happy is a unique experience, something that that child may have for maybe a couple of years or maybe throughout their childhood. But I think it's really that that family environment and the ways that adults are motivated to engage with that child that makes a difference. As a second child or third child
或者具有特定的特征或个性。相反，我更愿意考虑孩子们所处的家庭环境。如果你是长子，你进入的家庭可能有两个父母，家里可能还有其他成年人，但可能没有其他孩子。只有你。你被这些高度有动力确保你安全、健康、快乐的成年人养大的经历是一种独特的经历，这可能是那个孩子持续几年或者整个童年都拥有的经历。但我认为，真正起作用的是那个家庭环境以及成年人与该孩子互动的动力方式。随着第二个孩子或第三个孩子，
enters the household, you're talking about parents who are more experienced. This is not their first rodeo. They may have some ideas and expectations for how the second child might be and what that's going to be like raising that child. However, the experience of being a second time parent is, I think, really unique because it's not just adding another child and, you know, doing more diapers and feeding yet another child. It's learning how to nurture this new relationship between children who are very young and don't really have a lot of skills for building and sustaining a positive relationship. And it can create a lot of stress and anxiety for parents as well. As a third child, fourth child enters, again, the family environment is going to look very different
进入家庭，你谈论的是更有经验的父母。这不是他们的第一次经历。他们可能对第二个孩子会是什么样以及抚养那个孩子会是什么样有一些想法和期望。然而，作为第二次当父母的经历，我认为真的很独特，因为这不仅仅是增加另一个孩子，你知道，做更多的尿布和喂养另一个孩子。而是学习如何在很小、实际上没有多少建立和维持积极关系技能的儿童之间培养这种新关系。这也可能会给父母带来很大的压力和焦虑。随着第三个孩子、第四个孩子的加入，同样的，家庭环境看起来会非常不同，
because the parents do have more experience. They understand what it's like to nurture relationships among children. And they have other life skills. So I think in some ways, you know, it's really interesting to think about how families evolve as subsequent children enter it and then later leave it. Yeah, I think that's a really good point. And we tend to think of siblings and we'll say, and I might have already said this today, They share a household, they share an environment, but they also have unique experiences
因为父母确实有更多的经验。他们懂得如何在儿童之间培养关系。他们还有其他的生存技能。所以我认为在某些方面，思考随着后续孩子的加入然后后来离开，家庭是如何演变的，这真的是很有趣的。是的，我认为这是一个很好的观点。我们往往认为兄弟姐妹，我们也会说，我今天可能已经说过了，他们共享一个家庭，他们共享一个环境，但他们也有独特的经历，
depending on the things that Dr. Kramer just described. And some of that may carry through that if you're a firstborn, you may be the first to leave the parental home. You may have certain expectations and you may serve as a role model for your other siblings. So there are those things that are happening or maybe other family transitions happen in your childhood that didn't happen in your brother or sister's childhood. So we have a shared environment, but we also have unique experiences. And I think birth order plays a role in how we experience our family relationships. Let's talk for a minute about parental favoritism, which is something
取决于克雷默博士刚刚描述的事情。其中一些可能会持续下去，如果你是老大，你可能是第一个离开父母家的人。你可能会有某些期望，你可能会成为其他兄弟姐妹的榜样。所以这些事情正在发生，或者你的童年中发生了其他家庭转变，而你的兄弟或姐妹的童年中没有发生。所以我们有一个共享的环境，但我们也有独特的经历。我认为出生顺序在我们体验家庭关系的过程中起着一定的作用。我们花一分钟来谈谈父母的偏心，这是你们俩都研究过的事情。
that you've both studied. Children often feel that their parents have a favorite child. Is this really as common as kids think? And is it a big problem? And how does it affect siblings' relationships with one another? Well, I can talk about it from the adolescent perspective. We've done some interesting studies looking at adolescence perceptions of being treated the same or differently by their mothers and fathers. And we've learned a lot. We learned that, first of all, that children don't always expect to be treated the same
孩子们常常觉得他们的父母偏爱某个孩子。这真的像孩子们想象的那样普遍吗？这真的是一个大问题吗？它如何影响兄弟姐妹彼此之间的关系？嗯，我可以从青少年的角度来谈谈。我们做了一些有趣的研究，探讨青少年对母亲和父亲对待他们是否相同或不同的看法。我们学到了很多。我们了解到，首先，孩子们并不总是期望得到与兄弟姐妹相同的对待，
as a brother or sister, but they do expect to be treated fairly. and they really want their parents to recognize who they are as individuals, what their needs and characteristics and interests are, and to work towards meeting those. When they see that a sibling is being treated differently than them, they think about it and they judge it and they form attributions to try to understand why that is. And most importantly, they look at whether they think it's fair or not.
但他们确实期望得到公平对待，他们真的希望父母能够认识到他们作为个体的身份，他们的需求、特征和兴趣是什么，并努力去满足这些需求。当他们看到兄弟姐妹受到与自己不同的对待时，他们会思考、评判并形成归因，试图理解为什么会这样。最重要的是，他们会考虑他们认为这是否公平。
If they can come up with a good reason for why their brother got that new set of pajamas and they didn't, they're cool with it. If they can understand why they get a later bedtime than a younger sibling and can come up with a reasonable explanation for that, they're fine with that. But what was also fascinating was that we asked the same questions of their mothers and fathers. And we learned that when you're looking at four people in a family, two parents, two siblings, in adolescence, they don't always agree about what's even. happening. In fact, they agreed maybe about 33% of the time. And I found that absolutely fascinating. They could talk about these events, but they didn't always agree what was happening, who was being
如果他们能为哥哥买了那套新睡衣而自己没有买找到一个充分的理由，他们会释怀的。如果他们能理解为什么他们比年幼的弟弟睡得晚，并且能对此做出合理的解释，他们对此也很好。但同样迷人的是，我们对他们的母亲和父亲提出了同样的问题。我们了解到，当你看着一个家庭中的四个人（两个父母，两个兄弟姐妹）处于青春期时，他们对于究竟发生了什么并不总是一致的。事实上，他们达成一致的几率大概只有百分之三十三左右。我发现这绝对令人着迷。他们可以谈论这些事情，但他们并不总是对正在发生的事情、谁得到了更好的对待有一致的看法，而且他们还报告说，他们很少谈论差异对待。
treated better, and they also reported that they rarely talk about differential treatment. What I find remarkable about this is I have studied parental differential treatment or favoritism. in middle age, into people's 60s. So a much different stage of a life course, and what we find is very consistent. So children, adult children in this case, often perceive favoritism, and they will be able to articulate that.
我对此感到非常了不起的是，我研究了中年直至六十岁人群中的父母差异对待或偏心。所以这是人生历程中一个截然不同的阶段，我们发现的结果是非常一致的。因此，在这种情况下，成年子女经常能感知到偏心，并且能够表达出来。
Similarly, if they feel that it's just or fair, it doesn't seem to be as consequential, but if they do not perceive that it is just or fair, it has large consequences for their relationships with their sibling and also their psychological well-being. But we also asked their parents, their perceptions of children that they perceive to be most emotionally close to. We ask questions about preferences for caregiving. So the adult children's perception and the parents' perceptions are, again, not very consistent. So these families are all an agreement that it's happening. They're aware. There's the sense that it's there in the family,
同样地，如果他们觉得这是公正或公平的，似乎就没那么重要了，但如果他们认为这不公正或不公平，就会对他们与兄弟姐妹的关系以及他们的心理健康产生重大影响。但我们也询问了他们的父母，关于他们认为自己在情感上最亲近的孩子的看法。我们询问了关于照料偏好的问题。因此，成年子女的感知和父母的感知同样不是很一致。所以这些家庭都认为这种现象正在发生，他们意识到了。有一种感觉认为它存在于家庭中，
but where it actually is directed toward or what is happening, very little agreement. I would say, I guess, about the same, around 30%. So maybe these are also patterns that are carrying out throughout the life course. So it's not unusual to grow up and kind of say to your brother or sister, boy, where did you grow up? It's not my experience at all. Mom always liked you better anyway. Yeah, and that we would carry those feelings with us for decades of our lives. But when we ask, so these are older mothers and fathers that we're asking in their 70s and 80s, they're expressing favoritism, but it is not matching their kids' perception, their adult children's perceptions of favoritism.
但它实际上指向哪里或者正在发生什么，几乎没有共识。我想说，大概是一样的，在百分之三十左右。所以也许这也是贯穿整个人生历程的模式。所以长大后对哥哥或姐姐说：“天哪，你在哪里长大的？这根本不是我的体验。反正妈妈总是更喜欢你。”这并不罕见。是的，我们把这些感受带在身边几十年。但当我们询问时，这些是我们在他们七十多岁和八十多岁时询问的老年母亲和父亲，他们表达了偏心，但这与他们的孩子、成年子女对偏心的感知并不相符。
What can parents do to be more aware of this with their kids so that they're not really treating them differently, that they're treating them fairly? I think opening up conversation about these issues is really important. I was stunned by the fact that family members said that they rarely talked about these issues. Children and adolescents may say that they complain about these issues, and parents may actually acknowledge that their kids have complained about unfair treatment. But parents also report quickly dismissing those concerns or defending their behavior. Instead of, you know, opening up conversation about it, asking, what makes you feel that, you know, I favored your brother in this circumstance?
父母可以做些什么来让他们对孩子的这种现象有更多的意识，这样他们就不会真的区别对待他们，而是公平对待他们？我认为开启关于这些问题的对话真的很重要。家庭成员说他们很少谈论这些问题，这个事实让我感到震惊。儿童和青少年可能会说他们抱怨这些问题，而父母实际上可能承认他们的孩子抱怨过不公平的对待。但父母也会迅速驳回这些担忧或为自己的行为辩护。而不是，你知道的，就此展开对话，问：“是什么让你觉得，你知道的，我在这种情况下偏心了你的哥哥？
Let's talk about it. Because I do think that whereas children need to have some help in creating some accurate attributions about why their parents behaved in particular ways, that can happen through conversations with parents. but I think parents also need to be open to the idea that perhaps they need to have a better sense of how some of their choices and behaviors have been perceived by their children. And if they understood that, that might lead them to change some of their behaviors. I would also add, especially in my experience, maybe professionals working with later life families can be aware that these preferences also exist and to help to facilitate these types of conversations. because if families are not having them when adult children are middle-aged and parents are
我们谈谈吧。”因为我确实认为，虽然孩子们需要一些帮助来对父母为什么会有特定行为做出准确的归因，但这可以通过与父母的对话来实现。但我认为父母也需要对这样一种想法持开放态度，即也许他们需要更好地了解他们的某些选择和行为是如何被他们的孩子感知的。如果他们理解了这一点，可能会促使他们改变一些行为。我还想补充一点，尤其是在我的经验中，也许与晚年家庭合作的专业人士可以意识到这些偏好的存在，并帮助促进这些类型的对话。因为如果当成年子女处于中年而父母年纪较大时，家庭没有进行这些对话，他们就会在没有这些对话的情况下度过几十年。但现在我们从研究中得知，这正在对这些家庭如何驾驭晚年护理产生影响。所以也许如果我们能促进这些类型的对话并在那个时候进行干预，我们也许可以修复其中一些问题，以创造更好的晚年体验。
older, they have gone decades without having these conversations. But now we know from our research that it's having consequences for how these families are navigating later life care. And so maybe if we could facilitate these types of conversations and intervene at that point, we can maybe repair some of these issues to create better. later life experiences. So how much does it matter if siblings are close in age or far apart in age? What does that do to the dynamic? And are kids who are closer in age emotionally closer to each other? Or is that just a recipe for more squabbling in competition? Both. You can find studies that will support all of those hypotheses, to be honest.
那么，兄弟姐妹年龄相近还是相差很大有多大关系呢？这对家庭动态有什么影响？年龄相近的孩子在情感上更亲密吗？还是这只是导致更多争吵和竞争的秘诀？两者皆有。老实说，你可以找到支持所有这些假设的研究。
You know, there's some advantages to being close in age to a sibling because you may have similar experiences, see the world in similar ways, be able to really help one another. But there's also some advantages to having a sibling who's, you know, substantially older or younger. It offers opportunities to help, to teach, to give care, learn all of those skills. as well. But what I do like to tell parents is that making that decision about how to space your children, if they're lucky enough to be able to make a decision around that in the first place, is only one decision that they may get to make. Every day, they have countless opportunities
你知道的，与兄弟姐妹年龄相近有一些优势，因为你们可能有相似的经历，以相似的方式看待世界，能够真正地互相帮助。但有一个年龄大大长于或短于你的兄弟姐妹也有一些优势。它提供了帮助、教导、给予照顾、学习所有这些技能的机会。
and countless decisions they can make about things that they can do to help their children find ways to develop a positive relationship with one another. Yeah, I agree completely. And I was just going to add to, yeah, so advantages and disadvantages to the spacing and you'll find different research. There is some research to show, too, that maybe parents who have children who are a little further spaced apart may be able to give more resources to the individual children. So maybe some of these feelings of fairness or justice might be affected by spacing. But really, yes, if parents are thinking ahead to make these choices. And when we get into adulthood, it kind of equals out a little bit that now everyone is in adulthood.
同样。但我喜欢告诉父母的是，决定如何安排孩子的生育间隔（如果他们足够幸运能够首先围绕这个做出决定的化）只是他们可能做出的众多决定之一。每天，他们都有无数的机会，
So I think we see less of that in the adult literature. So Dr. Kramer, you have this program, the more fun with sisters and brothers. Can you talk a little bit about that and how that works and maybe tell our listeners how they might access some of those tools that you've created? Yes, absolutely. So I've been studying the factors that predict good sibling relationships. positive sibling relationships, not perfect sibling relationships. And we've identified a set of competencies and skills that we think are highly predictive of positive relationships over time.
并且可以做出无数的决定，关于他们可以做些什么来帮助他们的孩子找到培养彼此积极关系的方法。是的，我完全同意。我正想补充一点，是的，生育间隔有利有弊，你会发现不同的研究。也有一些研究表明，生育间隔稍大一点的父母可能能够为单个孩子提供更多的资源。所以也许公平或正义感的一些感觉可能会受到间隔的影响。但实际上，是的，如果父母提前考虑做出这些选择。当我们进入成年期时，情况会有所平衡，现在每个人都进入成年期了。所以我认为我们在成人文献中看到这种情况较少。那么克雷默博士，您有这个项目，“与姐妹兄弟共享更多乐趣”。您能简单谈谈这个项目以及它是如何运作的，并也许告诉我们的听众他们如何才能获取您创建的一些工具吗？是的，绝对可以。所以一直在研究预测良好兄弟姐妹关系的因素。积极的兄弟姐妹关系，而不是完美的兄弟姐妹关系。我们已经确定了一组我们认为随着时间的推移高度预测积极关系的能力和技能。
And so we've taken that information and translated it into a program for children and for parents. So I, for many years, offered an in-person program, a version of more fun with siblings. sisters and brothers, where we brought in children, siblings from three or four families, created a group and directly taught kids these skills. Parents would watch from a viewing area, and I'd sit with the parents and explain what we were doing and coached parents so that they could keep up these skills at home and help their kids really learn how to apply them and when they needed to use them. It was very effective for increasing positivity in siblings,
因此，我们获取了这些信息，并将其转化为针对儿童和家长的项目。多年来，我一直提供一种面对面的项目，即“与兄弟姐妹共度更多快乐”的一个版本。在这个版本中，我们会邀请来自三四个家庭的孩子和兄弟姐妹组成一个小组，直接教给孩子们这些技能。家长们则在一个观赏区观看，我会和家长们坐在一起，解释我们在做什么，并指导家长，以便他们能在家里继续运用这些技能，帮助他们的孩子们真正学会如何应用这些技能以及何时需要使用它们。这对于增进兄弟姐妹间的积极关系非常有效，
relationships, helping kids learn how to manage conflict. And most importantly, I think, helping kids manage some of the negative emotions that come with frustrating sibling relationships. I realized that as great as the program seemed to be, we were only able to access a limited number of people at one time with this program. And we were limited in terms of geography. So we now have it as an online program for parents. So we're teaching the same sorts of skills, but now we're teaching parents how to, what these skills are, what's really important about them, and how they can use them with their own children to actually be the teachers and coaches themselves. So we're doing an online study of this right now. Interested parents can take a look at fun with sisters and brothers.
包括增进关系、帮助孩子们学习如何处理冲突。最重要的是，我认为它能帮助孩子们处理那些伴随着令人沮丧的兄弟姐妹关系而产生的负面情绪。我意识到，尽管这个项目看起来很棒，但我们一次只能让有限数量的人参与，而且在地理位置上也受到了限制。所以我们现在把它做成了面向家长的在线项目。因此，我们正在教授同类技能，但现在我们是在教家长这些技能是什么、它们为什么如此重要，以及他们如何将其运用到自己的孩子身上，从而自己成为真正的老师和教练。所以我们目前正在对此进行一项在线研究。感兴趣的家长可以去看看“与兄弟姐妹共度快乐”项目。
org. The program is designed for families who have two children between the ages of four to eight years. So that's the target group. And you need to speak English or feel comfortable reading in English and listening in English. But beyond that, we've been really excited that as an online vehicle, we have participants from all over the world engaged with us. So it is a research study. So we do ask parents to complete a set of questionnaires for us at the beginning, middle, and end of the program. But it's a self-paced four-lusson program. And we're excited to have more families during us. And Dr. Gillian, for those of us who didn't have the benefit of a program like this as kids, I mean, what do we do as adults to make our relationships better?
org。该项目专为有两个4至8岁孩子的家庭设计。这就是目标群体。你需要会说英语，或者觉得阅读和听力英语都很自在。但除此之外，我们感到非常兴奋的是，作为一个在线平台，我们吸引了来自世界各地的参与者参与其中。所以这是一项研究。因此，我们确实要求家长在项目开始、中期和结束时为我们完成一套问卷。但这一个是一个节奏自主的四课时项目。我们很高兴有更多的家庭加入我们。吉利安博士，对于我们这些在小时候没有享受过这样项目的人来说，我的意思是，作为成年人，我们该怎么做才能改善我们的关系呢？
short of psychotherapy, which I know works, but are there any other resources out there that could help people who want to have better relationships as adults with their siblings? Yeah, so one of the things that my colleagues and I talk about is as maybe we as researchers are developing, hopefully, those type of resources, it is something to be aware of. So being aware of your sibling relationships and how they may be impacting your well-being. And we have been talking a lot publicly about how do we incorporate this into family therapy? How do we make sure that professionals working with families are aware of, you know, thinking about your romantic relationships, thinking about maybe your work relationships, but your sibling relationships might be a place that you also need to work on and think about.
除了心理治疗——我知道这很管用，但还有没有其他资源可以帮助那些作为成年人希望与兄弟姐妹建立更好关系的人呢？是的，我和我的同事们讨论的事情之一是，也许我们作为研究人员正在开发（希望如此）这类资源，这是需要意识到的一点。也就是要意识到你的兄弟姐妹关系以及它们可能如何影响你的福祉。我们一直在公开讨论，我们如何将这一点融入家庭治疗中？我们如何确保与家庭合作的专业人士意识到，你知道的，除了考虑你的恋爱关系、考虑你的工作关系外，你的兄弟姐妹关系可能也是一个你需要努力和思考的地方。
So I think just raising awareness that your sibling relationships and adulthood may be impacting your psychological and physical health and being willing to talk about that and being open to discussion about that. So what are the next frontiers in these areas? What are you both looking at? Where do we have to go? I mean, I'm always asking questions about COVID. I'm sure that COVID and everybody being locked up together for two years is going to have some interesting impacts on sibling relationships. Is that? anything that you're looking at right now? I think it's been really important to have an online tool to share with families during COVID. We've been really impressed with the interest among parents, but also providers and educators, you know, who are very sensitive to the fact that, you know, especially during lockdown, this was really a critical issue for families. What do we do all day?
所以我认为，只需提高人们的认识，即成年后的兄弟姐妹关系可能会影响你的心理和身体健康，并且愿意谈论这一点，对关于这一点的讨论持开放态度。那么这些领域的下一个前沿是什么？你们两个都在关注什么？我们必须走向何方？我的意思是，我总是问关于新冠疫情的问题。我确信新冠疫情以及每个人被关在一起两年，会对兄弟姐妹关系产生一些有趣的影响。是这样吗？这是你们现在正在关注的事情吗？我认为在疫情期间拥有一个与家庭分享的在线工具非常重要。我们对家长以及服务提供商和教育工作者的兴趣印象深刻，你知道的，他们对这样一个事实非常敏感，即特别是禁闭期间，这确实是家庭的一个关键问题。我们整天都在做什么？
and, you know, when kids are unhappy with one another, that just creates a very difficult family environment. So I think understanding these different contexts are really going to be very important. I feel that the developmental approach kind of, you know, reflected in Dr. Gilligan's work and my own is so important. I've spent so much time with four to eight-year-olds. I'm ready to go to eight to 12-year-olds soon. Adolescence, what can we do? But I do believe that prevention is certainly a very important tool. And as we really come to appreciate the value and importance of sibling relationships across the life course, I do believe that we'll do a better job of helping families be much more proactive in helping their kids find productive ways to get along
而且，你知道的，当孩子们对彼此感到不满意时，这只会创造一个非常困难的家庭环境。所以我认为理解这些不同的背景将是非常重要的。我觉得吉利安博士的工作和我自己的工作中所体现的那种发展方法是非常重要的。我在4到8岁的孩子身上花了太多时间。我准备很快转向8到12岁的孩子。青春期，我们能做什么？但我确实相信预防肯定是一个非常重要的工具。随着我们真正开始欣赏兄弟姐妹关系在整个生命历程中的价值和重要性，我确实相信，在帮助家庭以更加积极主动的方式帮助孩子找到相处的高效方法方面，我们会做得更好，
and be equipped to manage the conflicts that are inevitable. Yeah, I agree completely. My colleagues and I are doing some work right now where we're following sibling relationships from adolescents into middle age. And one of the emerging findings is that we carry those early relationships with us on our well-being outcomes. And so I think, you know, as we move past this idea of, well, we kind of grow out of that or that's just, that's just kids stuff. But no, these are relationships we carry with us or adulthood, and we carry the consequences with them. I will share too. I'm also working on research right now during COVID.
并且具备管理不可避免的冲突的能力。是的，我完全同意。我和我的同事们目前正在做一些工作，我们正在追踪从青春期到中年时期的兄弟姐妹关系。其中一个新出现的发现是，我们将早期的关系带入了我们的福祉结果中。所以我想，你知道的，随着我们抛弃这种想法，即“哦，我们总会长大，不再那样”或者“那只是小孩子的把戏”。但事实并非如此，这些是我们带入成年期的关系，我们也要承担随之而来的后果。我还要分享的是，我目前也在做一项关于新冠疫情的研究。
We're with adult siblings who are providing care to older parents with dementia, Alzheimer's disease and related dementia. And we are also using technology and realizing how increasingly dependent over the last two years siblings have become on using video conferencing and phone to communicate with each other to navigate care for older parents. I think technology is playing an increasingly important role in maintaining sibling relationships and also for siblings to do the tasks that they need to do together. Well, I want to thank you both for joining me today.
我们的对象是照顾患有痴呆症、阿尔茨海默病及相关痴呆症的老年父母的成年兄弟姐妹。我们也在使用技术，并意识到在过去两年里，兄弟姐妹越来越依赖视频会议和电话来彼此沟通，以协调对老年父母的照顾。我认为技术在维持兄弟姐妹关系以及兄弟姐妹共同完成他们需要完成的任务方面，正扮演着越来越重要的角色。嗯，我想感谢你们两位今天能来参加我的节目。
This has been really interesting. I could go on for another 40 minutes, but I very much appreciate your joining me today. Thank you. Thank you so much. Yes, thank you for having us. You can learn more about Dr. Kramer's and Dr. Gilligan's work in the March issue of APA's magazine monitor on psychology. Find a link in our show notes at www. www. speaking of psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of
这真的很有趣。我可以再聊40分钟，但我非常感谢你们今天能来。谢谢。非常感谢。是的，谢谢你们邀请我们。您可以从美国心理学协会《心理学观察》杂志三月号中了解更多关于克雷默博士和吉利安博士的工作。请在我们的节目简介中找到链接，网址是 www. speaking of psychology.org。您还可以找到往期的节目
Speaking of Psychology there or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen on Apple, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at a.pa.org. That's Speaking of Psychology all one word at a.pa.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kandayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在那里收听，或在Apple、Stitcher或任何您获取播客的地方收听。如果您在Apple上收听，请给我们留个评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at a.pa.org。也就是 Speaking of Psychology 连在一起，在 a.pa.org。Speaking of Psychology 由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·坎达扬（Chris Kandayan）。谢谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。